welcome to the vlog guys so today we are
going to talk about the top three
programming languages for data science
and before we do that I want to talk
about my life because I'm a youtuber and
I'm a narcissist and I need constant
validation from you guys so a little
update I'm in LA now so I'm taking a
short vacation because then I felt a
little bit burnt out from work so I
wanted to chill and do nothing for like
a few days and the perfect person to do
that with my brother we have a special
guest David MA and this is what we did
when we were here yeah but since I'm an
aspiring filmmaker that's how I saw it
[Music]
anyways so I'm gonna go back home now
I'm gonna have to go find a scooter so I
could scoot back home see you later okay
alright this is my bed this is the
Nintendo switch I've been playing a lot
of Celeste super fun alright let's get
started
so so I'm going to answer this question
real quick and I'm going to answer it
for data science analytics because
that's what I know so the top three
programming languages are Python R and
sequel that's it and I actually don't
even like answering these questions
because it's just so different in terms
of the languages in their use case like
for example sequel isn't even a
programming language but I still put it
there because it's quite important to
have or at least to know how to use it
because no matter what data you use you
have to use something to query it so
that's sequel and I wouldn't even
consider having to learn sequel because
it's basically just the tool to grab
data out of the database so in some ways
it's kind of saying like learning how to
use Windows computer or learning how to
write URLs to access the internet like
I'm exaggerating a little bit but that's
kind of how I feel about it anyway so
here's why I chose Python as number one
Python and are both have the best
packages related to stats are the
programming language is basically made
for numerical computations so that's why
R has a vast range of statistical
packages that you can use and they're
all open source even more so than Python
but the thing about Python is it wasn't
built for numerical computation
for stats or anything like that Python
was built for a clear programming it was
built for code readability
so then Python got more attention from
developers and then because of that
developers would soon start to develop
more frameworks or libraries to support
the Python language like for example web
frameworks like flask Django they were
all built for Python and then because
it's so popular it also drew attention
from the stats people and they probably
really like the language because it's
clean so then that's why the stats
people started developing you know Sai
kit pandas Jupiter notebooks everything
that you need to make statistical
analysis and it's a little bit of a
virtuous cycle because the more you have
support for numerical computation the
more people will use it and because the
more people use it the more frameworks
will be developed and more support it
would have so for example tensorflow for
machine learning they provided a Python
API NSC API and the reason they provide
a Python API I'm not sure I think it's
because Python is so popular amongst the
machine learning developers or
statisticians or maybe even the own data
scientist in Kwon's because python is
already so popular and tensorflow
decided to have an API for Python and C
so basically python is just super
popular and it has tons of resources
online and more and more people I feel
are moving away from R and starting to
use Python for their statistical
analysis they use Jupiter notebook it's
super nice because it's a way to
organize your notebooks and a way to
present your analysis R is still a very
very good option and I mean when you
think about it R is literally built for
statistical computing so it's pretty
damn good however it is less flexible
like imagine if suddenly you want to
start making websites yeah you're not
gonna make a web back-end using are you
there's no frameworks for that I don't
think so and finally sequel you just
need it you're just gonna need it
everywhere no matter what you do you
don't even need to be a data scientist
you might be just be a software engineer
and you want to query some data for
testing purpose
or maybe to validate your feature or
something like that you're still going
to need to pull that data somewhere and
usually it's from a database and in most
database
except for no sequel most relational
databases they use sequel as their
language so you should just know it so
that's pretty much it that's top three
programming languages for data science
now I just want to thank wrong Sam for
supporting this channel much much
appreciate it and also Joshua pop asked
what is one social thing and one
technical thing you wished you learned
in college that would have helped
prepare you for the tech industry well
the thing I will say is not super tied
to tech industry it's more about me as a
as a person and my personal growth but
the one social thing is I wish I was a
better leader and communicator at work
if you take initiative and you
communicate really clearly what you're
going to do and what for you'll do a lot
better than most new grads I was always
a bad leader you know I I got nobody
listens to me and I'm not very assertive
so I wish that I was better at that and
also you know I have sometimes trouble
communicating what's on my mind
and my ideas or even my road map to my
peers and then because of that I get
affected negatively so I wish I was
better at that so for the technical
thing I wish I learned iOS development
because if ever I want to quickly
protect an app or an app idea then I can
do it a lot easier if I know iOS
development and most of the apps
nowadays they have a mobile component to
it and because I didn't know how to do
iOS development
I couldn't execute on some ideas that I
wanted to because I just suck at
front-end programming and I feel like
that's been always my limiting factor I
just really suck at front-end
development I can quickly build api's or
you know wet backends with databases and
all that that stuff is simple a man
front-end
I suck so much anyways before I go
there's a quick word from our sponsor
today by the way this video was
sponsored by brilliant org which is kind
of cool because I actually used trillion
org when I was applying to my untitled
large company since the company gave me
links to help me prepare for my
interview and one of the links that they
gave me is a bunch of combinatorics
questions
aka probability questions on brilliant
org it really helped me on the math part
of the interview because I was killing
the probability questions I actually
find it really fun to crank out these
questions it makes me feel good about
myself and keeps me sharp and they're
good brain teasers for interviews
especially for data science or quantity
very good supplement to my interview
preps so highly recommended also if
you're in school you could supplement
your learning by using this website
because there's a wide variety of topics
which is pretty dope because I love the
UI on the website and it makes studying
so much more fun with their quizzes if
you're interested there's a link in the
description down below best of all you
can get 20% off their premium
subscription so you too you can kill it
at the interview for the large entitled
company alright and that's it for the
vlog I hope you enjoyed this video now
I'm just gonna add some random clips so
that I can extend this video to ten
minutes so I could get more ad revenue
so I guess I guess you can watch me play
video games or something
acting awful days nothing to deny
I do justice
[Music]